à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
sylvie venez avec moi je vois des veines
avec moi qu'est-ce qu'ils sont beaux les
deux prêtres sans déconner j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un cours de
tango qui se basait amener quelque chose
qui a manqué votre regard des gens qui
ont passé leurs vacances à la montagne
et ça n'est pas c'est quoi c'est la
neige
[Applaudissements]
oh la la
dans sa belle robe
non
[Applaudissements]
k
m
josé on nous avant d'été on va jouer
tous les deux ont des glaces et on va en
lancer les dés à chaque fois celui qui
fera le plus petit nombre devra à chaque
fois
ce verset de la neige ou dans le dos ou
dans le slip c'est son usage je sais
déjà où je vais la mettre
attention où l'eau qu'il est chanceux
alors attention attention
oui les ténors première oui oui quand
même temps m et l'ami à oui oui celle
amassée dans ce cas là bien que ça je
suis moyens j'étais un peu ado non c'est
pas le ballon alors on peut changer de
dire vous inquiétez pas ça mais un jour
de vous enrichir
je compte bien sympa
[Applaudissements]
rien n'est fait maintenant il faut
refermer jean avrillas compte cinq
minutes à faire
en espérant que ça ne marque pas la zone
on va faire ça celle là ouais t'as peur
d'eux on l'a on la met roula mais comme
ça comme ça comme ça d'accord
l'autre là messieurs la personne super
d'entre eux mêmes être là parce que là
la salle où sérieux attention j'ai le
slip en feu l'a donc là à tuer un par un
ah bah oui comme ça je vais monter la
sauce avec
[Applaudissements]
quel truc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
josé garcia lors du money money
[Musique]